i'm rosalyn cyrus i go by roz so i have
been a designer for about
15 years and that encompasses web design
application design anything like that
but when it comes to
programming i sort of fell in love with
it and
have always had a knack for just doing
it on the side the two disciplines
feed into each other and off of each
other and so the way i like to think
about it is
if you can
make something beautiful just by looking
at it
there's no reason why you can't also
make something beautiful by creating it
or constructing it i'll give you an
example from when i first graduated
undergrad
that
gave me some insight into me thinking
development would be something i love
i at the time i don't remember what
website it was it was some website where
it would show you the time of day and
you know the actual dates
does it know that that's the time of day
and you know i would look at the source
code to see if there was any insight and
it would just have the time of day
printed there but i was wondering well
how does it know how is it actually
calculated and i would look up ways to
do that and that's when you know php was
a big deal and that's that's literally
what made me start learning php because
i learned that you can have dynamic
content and i never knew about this
concept of dynamic content
so that was how i knew early on that the
fact that i was so curious to figure out
this one thing that i went and picked up
a programming language because of it
was how i knew i had what it took i had
the determination and the curiosity
to
pursue something like this and that was
years before you know i was even in the
bay area
and so i think i just always knew i had
this burning curiosity inside of me to
solve problems
whether it's um through designer code
like i said and it just it fit right in
with the way my brain already works just
trying to
break things apart and put them back
together in a better way so at the time
i was living in the bay area and had a
roommate who was getting into
development or at least peaking his
interest and he was taking a course
through that graduate certificate and
said hey roz i know you dabble in this
would you like to
look at this and maybe take a course
with me and i said sure so i looked at
the courses that they were offering and
i said this seems like it would be
perfect for me because you know one of
my mattresses you don't know what you
don't know and me being self-taught
i might have a certain level of
confidence but i would never think i'm
good enough to just say oh i don't need
that program i've got this so i decided
to just enroll with him and that very
first course was cs 106 b
which is a second level intro course to
computer science
and i was just blown away it was
incredible um
i think the challenging thing though was
i was so far removed from undergrad and
i was so used to the working world that
i had to remember how to be a student so
that was definitely a challenge but
that's sort of how i got the ball
rolling and funny enough my roommate not
to call him out my roommate at the time
that was the one and only class he took
i kept going with it because i loved it
so much and i initially didn't even have
the master's program in my mind at all i
really was just going for the four or
five courses for the certificate
and by the time i was a few courses in
one of my professors said raj you really
should apply for the master's program
and then that planted a seed in my head
and then i went ahead and applied and
it's been you know the rest is history